imaginons une personne un observateur
immobile sur la planète terre qui
regarde un vaisseau spatial passés dans
l'espace devant lui à la vitesse v une
vitesse très élevée proche de celle de
la lumière
si une personne dans le vaisseau lui
montre son horloge la personne ici
l'observateur sur terre va observer que
ces aiguilles les aiguilles de l'horloge
dans le vaisseau tourne plus lentement
que les aiguilles de la personne sur
terre c'est un phénomène qu'on appelle
la dilatation des durées et qui est
d'ailleurs relatif la personne dans le
vaisseau elle a l'impression que c'est
la terre qui se déplace dans l'autre
sens et donc pour la personne enlevée
saut c'est la personne sur terre dont
l'horloge semble tourner au ralenti
l'objectif de cette vidéo ça va être de
calculer le rapport entre le rythme
auquel s'écoule le temps sur chacune des
deux horloges alors pour faire ça on va
noter tôt le temps de cette horloge de
l'horloge dans le vaisseau était le
temps porté par l'observateur et on va
imaginer un axe x sur lequel
l'observateur mesure la position du
vaisseau pour en particulier déterminer
sa vitesse lors de cette façon on a une
sorte de diagrammes d'espace-temps avec
le temps tu est mesurée par
l'observateur est la position du
vaisseau x mesurer également par
l'observateur et dans ce diagramme
d'espace-temps le vaisseau trace une
sorte de diagonale il avance vers le
futur mais il se déplace également dans
l'espace au cours du temps la pente de
cette diagonale dx sur d'été
c'est simplement la vitesse du vaisseau
c'est la distance qu'ils parcourent / le
temps qui s'est écoulé du point de vue
de l'observateur
alors imaginons un intervalle de temps
mesuré par l'observateur donc dû tenter
cet intervalle on peut imaginer que
c'est une seconde par exemple on va
l'appeler plus généralement d'été dans
cet intervalle de temps le vaisseau
s'est déplacée à l'intérieur d'une trame
la trame de l'univers qu'on appelle
l'espace temps donc c'est la trame qui
représentait dans le diagramme et donc
le vaisseau s'est déplacé dans cette
direction à travers l'espace temps et a
parcouru une certaine distance dans
l'espace temps alors il a parcouru une
distance dans l'espace qu'on peut noter
des x
et il a parcouru une distance dans le
temps et si d'été et tout ceci fait que
le vaisseau a parcouru une distance
globale dans l'espace temps qu on notera
ds
ici intervient une remarque très
importante le vaisseau de son point de
vue n'a pas l'impression d'être en
mouvement donc du point de vue du
vaisseau lui il est immobile son axe
temporel ceylac ce taux de son temps
propre donc c'est cet axe ici
de son point de vue c'est lui qui est
immobile et la terre qui se déplace dans
l'autre sens
et lax x en particulier lui semble
incliner
et donc pour l'observateur dans le
vaisseau le temps s'écoule tout à fait
normalement donc un intervalle ici est
un intervalle normal de temps la
personne dans le vaisseau ne se rend pas
compte qu'il y à une dilatation des
durées pour elle la dilatation des
durées se produit pour la personne sur
terre et en fait chacune des deux
personnes un temps qui s'écoule
normalement la différence est simplement
que les deux projette le temps de
l'autre sur leur propre axe et lorsqu on
projette la perspective la différence
d'orientation entre les axes fait que
les distances semble contracter ou
dilater donc ici la distance parcourue
dans l'espace temps par le la personne
dans le vaisseau par le vaisseau
correspond directement autant propre qui
s'est écoulée vu que c'est cette
distance est une distance sur l'app
store
donc c'est le temps propre qui s'est
écoulé pour la personne dans le vaisseau
à une différence près qu'il faut
multiplier par un facteur de conversion
puisqu'ici on parle d'une distance donc
en mettre par exemple
alors qu'ici le temps propre et en
seconde donc il faut multiplier par des
mètres par seconde pour obtenir une
distance et ce facteur de conversion
c'est ce qu'on appelle plus généralement
la vitesse de la lumière mais s'il faut
vraiment le voir comme un facteur pour
convertir les unités en partant des
secondes pour obtenir des maîtres
c'est cette expression qui est vraiment
très importante ici si on arrive à
déterminer la distance qu'a parcouru le
vaisseau s eh bien on peut directement
déterminer le temps propre qui s'est
écoulé pour le vaisseau des taux et à
partir de là comparer ce temps propre
des taux autant de l'observateur d'été
alors comment déterminer la distance
entre deux points a priori on voudrait
utiliser le théorème de pythagore qui
nous dirait que dsk ray l'hypoténuse est
égal à d'été carré plus dx carré
le problème c'est que dans
l'espace-temps la géométrie n'est pas au
client le théorème de pythagore ne
fonctionne pas alors il ya deux choses
là dedans une chose qui est un peu
triviale et une chose qui est vraiment
fondamental
la première chose c'est qu'on ne peut
pas 10 y aune et des secondes au carré
des maîtres au carré on peut pas
additionner deux grandeurs qui n'ont pas
la même unité donc ici comme je les dis
pour convertir les distance temporelle
en vraie distance spatiale pourquoi on
fait ça tout simplement pour voir les
additionner eh bien on va multiplier le
temps par un facteur de conversion la
vitesse de la lumière c
est donc ici on multiplie par ces
ocarian donc maintenant qu'on a fait ça
on a bien des mètres carrés ici et des
mètres carrés ici et donc on peut bien
additionner ces deux grandeurs
donc ce problème ce premier problème est
un peu triviale à régler c'est juste un
problème d'unité on veut utiliser les
mêmes unités pour comparer des grandeurs
le deuxième problème est beaucoup plus
fondamental c'est ce qui fait toute la
base de la relativité restreinte et même
de la relativité en général ici le dx
carré ne vient pas avec un signe plus
contrairement au théorème de pythagore
mais avec un signe - qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que plus le
vaisseau aura parcouru une grande
distance dans l'espace plus la distance
ici de l'hypothénuse la longueur de
l'hypoténuse est en réalité courte alors
bien sûr sur le diagramme sept longueurs
par est plus longue mais ce qui est très
étrange dans l'espace temps c'est qu'en
réalité cette longueur est plus courte
on dit que la métrique de l'espace temps
est une pseudo métriques ce n'est pas
une vraie mesure de distancer ne
satisfait pas les les conditions plus
intuitive de ce qu'on appellerait une
distance et c'est vraiment tout ce qui
crée
la particularité l'étrangeté de la
relativité
cette chose cette expression ici c'est
ce qu'on appelle la métrique de
minkowski et c'est ce qui permet
vraiment de mesurer des distances dans
l'espace temps
bon et bien à partir de cette expression
on a presque terminé ici le ds carré on
sait que ds vos c'est fouad et au
ca cds et donc dsk revo c'est carré fois
des taux au carré
d'autre part on sait que dx sur d'été
égale v et donc que dx est égal avec
fouad était
donc on peut écrire ici que ceux des
leaks carré vaut vkr et d'été carrier et
donc ces deux des taux 2 est égal à ces
deux tétées 2 - v 2 dt2
ici on a presque terminé il suffit de
réarranger un peu les termes pour
obtenir et donc on va se rappeler un peu
de ce qu'on souhaite obtenir c'est le
rapport entre taux était ou plus
précisément leur apport dans l'autre
sens d'été sur des taux c'est à dire
lorsque une seconde de temps propres
s'est écoulé pour la personne dans le
vaisseau combien de temps at il fallu
attendre pour la personne sur terre ce
rapport c'est ce qu'on appelle le
facteur de lawrence noté plus
communément gamma c'est le rapport qui
intervient tout le temps en relativité
restreinte et qu'on va ici pouvoir
déterminer en notant simplement que donc
d'été est égal à gamma fois des taux
alors utilisons cette expression ici on
a ces deux des taux 2 et gallas et 2 dt2
- v 2 dt2 donc tout ça on peut
factoriser la c2 - v2 facteur 2 dt2 et
des t2 vos gammes à 2 des taux 2 donc
tout ceci vaut gamme à 2 des taux de
sa cessé de des taux 2 donc en divisant
par des taux au carré on n'obtient que
ces carrés est égal à gamma deux fois
c'est de manger 2 et pour finir en
divisant par ces carrés on n'obtient que
1 est égal à 1 - v carrés sur ces carrés
x gamma au carré
alors là on peut diviser des deux côtés
par ce facteur et maître tout à la
racine carrée et on obtient l'expression
finale le facteur de lawrence gamme à
vos seins sur racine de 1 - v carrés sur
ces carrés
ce qu'on voit ici c'est que ce facteur
de lawrence est toujours plus grand que
1 en effet v carrés sur ces cars est
toujours positif donc tout ça est
toujours plus petit que 1 et donc
l'inversé toujours plus grand que 1 ce
que ça signifie c'est que pour la
personne sur terre le temps dans le
vaisseau semble toujours ralentis et de
la même façon pour la personne dans le
vaisseau s'il regarde le temps sur terre
le temps sur terre lui semble également
ralenti
d'autre part on observe que cette racine
carrée ce qui se trouve à l'intérieur
tend vers zéro lorsque v s'approche de
la vitesse de la lumière c'est ce qui
signifie que l' inverse de tout ça tend
vers un sur zéro vers l'infini en
d'autres termes la dilatation du temps
devient infinie lorsque le vaisseau
approche la vitesse de la lumière